boundary changes are being presented to
Clark County schools and some of these
could actually impact your kids the
major proposals Denise are for changes
in the growing Northwest and Southeast
Valley areas Joshua peguerra was at
today's meeting with why certain schools
are being impacted Joshua now these
changes are meant to ease the
overcrowding of high schools and with
several homes being developed in these
areas there's a concern that until more
schools are built things will get worse
Arbor View is packed there's 24
Portables there's no space available for
the kids to eat at lunch my son goes to
the school there so I'm very well aware
of the pack classroom sizes and there's
no space available for the for the
school to grow on its own sits on the
attendant Zone advisory commission that
covers the Northwest Valley the group
voted in favor of a proposal that moves
about 200 students from Arbor View High
School to Centennial it also sends 20
students from Indian Springs to
Centennial as you can see on the map
centennial's boundary has been expanded
that area is booming right now that it's
not just built and purchase permits they
are putting houses down Alex mcgurk has
a son at Arbor View High School she
thinks the zoning commission is ignoring
families in the far Northwest have more
future Development coming and we do not
have a school proposed until 2028 that
means we have to go six more years it
with only two high schools money has
been set aside for a new high school to
be built in Northwest Valley there are
currently 728 12th graders at Arbor View
and 625 a centennial another High School
boundary change focuses on Henderson
sending 277 Coronado students to Green
Valley High School Green Valley's
boundary is extending South to the 215
between Green Valley Parkway and
Stephanie this is to provide enrollment
relief for Coronado Anna Bender
represents this District right now you
know people complain a lot about our
schools being overcrowded but our most
overcrowded schools are our high schools
these new boundary changes still have to
be adopted by the Clark County School
District trustees that meeting is
scheduled for next Thursday Kirsten
thank you very much Joshua another
change includes shrinking the boundary
of Ellis Elementary School in Henderson
some students will now be sent to Wallen
Elementary